one of the things that you talk about
losing the Nobel Prize is the resistance
to the this idea that there was an
origin to the universe and specifically
that a lot of that was based in an
anti-religious sentiment which is this
looks a lot like the very beginning of
the Bible and that scares a lot of
scientists yeah so and back then in the
1950s and so forth when Fred Hoyle who's
an amazing astronomer he won you know
basically this the runner-up prize to
the Nobel Prize crayford press he ended
up uh saying that the reason that
scientists are so adamant about the Big
Bang is because they're obsessed with
Genesis 1 1. now can you imagine you
know Lawrence Krauss or something from
like I'm obsessed I have to prove that
Genesis won't I mean it's absurd and and
as you pointed out earlier most
scientists are at them and the majority
of the National Academy of Sciences most
prestigious organization on Earth are
declared atheist or you know 20 are
agnostic or don't know and 10 believe
say and so uh so it's interesting that
how much we've evolved just since the
1950s and then to actually have that
brought into focus and that people now
accept without a doubt that there was an
the beginning of what we call the
observable universe that does not mean
that we've witnessed time equals zero
and that's where things get really
interesting because we don't have a
theory that describes how properties of
matter of space and time itself I mean
have you ever thought let's say time
began what causes something to begin
when there's no something to begin with
to begin with right so how did time
change from nothing into something and
these are questions that have perfectly
good answers potentially but we don't
have the data so my job is to collect
that data or perhaps refute these models
by collecting data that that is
objectionable under those hypotheses so
in this particular context obviously a
lot of religious leaders say well got a
good answer for it already what kicked
off time but we have this whole
religious literature that's built around
the idea that there was a thing they
kicked off time and that thing was God
this is what we call God in the in the
uh the domestic model but the scientists
have been promoting a bunch of different
theories as to why the universe was
created the way that it was why it
exists in the way that it does and and
it seems like a lot of this is a
response to some of the arguments yes
that some religious Believers have made
about the fine-tuning of the universe
the idea that a certain number of things
had to go exactly right for us to be
here at this time and so you hear
arguments made on a fairly routine basis
about how well you know that's just how
Randomness Works we're just the lucky
ones and religious Believers argue back
well but why are we the lucky ones and
that's a pretty convenient argument that
we happen to be the lucky ones why
wouldn't we have been one of the
non-monkey ones exactly uh so how do you
how do you circle circle that square I
mean how do you how do you come down on
that particular debate I mean I think
for me it's so much fun to think about
these things so so nowadays you you know
you're alluding to the anthropic
principle which which I'll describe in a
minute and the Multiverse it's funny in
scientific circles with my scientist
friends I can't say Multiverse without
getting into a fight you know like you
say multi like we're going to take sides
and some people say that's not even
science or they'll say that's you know
that's pure nonsense or they'll say this
is the best answer that scientists have
and you know the the people out there
when they're not you know comparing me
to like Chen eager or whatever they'll
say this this guy believes that that you
know that they you know the hypothesis
which scientists just use as a working
tool and they'll reject it I mean they
have much more faith in kind of the
dispassionate scientists which has led
to this to this real you know Canard
almost and and overused stereotype that
scientists are there's these
dispassionate people that work have no
feelings have no objective have no
motive no biases and you know in the
book I got your account many different
uh biases prejudices that scientists
including me are afflicted by and I
think it's important to realize that
that when you have these discussions
when they turn heated and I think you
know it's interesting I never hear from
the religious I hear crazy things from
religious people you know that are just
non-scientific to bolster their own
hypothesis they're perfectly willing to
have confirmation bias sometimes too but
in the case of the scientists I think
they're again this is touching back on
some deep thing within them a sensitive
nerve that you know if there was
something true about religion then I
have all these obligations and I have
enough to do you know at The Faculty
Club already so I don't know yeah so as
I said it's the hardest three hour a
week job in the world but but you know
but I think it's it's very interesting
to to think about these questions of
what generated this new pursuit in
science was it a reaction to these
religious explanations so Robert jastrow
who worked at Goddard Space Center and
the he wrote a book called God and the
astronomers now he was a declared
agnostic and he said upon the discovery
of this cosmic background radiation that
I studied through telescopes like bicep
and the Simon's Observatory that people
came scientists who were secular climbed
to the top of the mountain and found a
band of theologians rejoicing up there
on the other hand when the Big Bang was
first proposed by by a Belgian priest
named lametra he implicitly told the
pope do not use this as evidence for the
creation Narrative of Genesis 1 1. and
he was intellectually honest about that
that this is not necessarily should not
be used again these are non-overlapping
magisteria and Stephen J Gould's
language these are not these are two
different things I mean uh to think
about you know reading the Bible as a
science book is absurd as reading a
brief history of time and thinking oh
that's how I'm going to raise my
children or that's my obligations as a
moral ethical being so I think I think
these these these controversies to me
are are so are so much fun because these
are two puzzles and we may never go to
the we may go to our Graves and not
answer these questions but to not think
about them I think it leaves a life of a
slight impoverishment that my colleagues
unfortunately many of them many of them
too love to think about and love to talk
about it though they stay in the closet
about it thank you for tuning in to the
Daily wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a like And subscribe to
our YouTube channel so you don't miss
out on any of our content